hi my name is presh
salvatika my name is pinuli chai i'm his
mother so this summer is really special
to us because we're going to be opening
our first restaurant at the thai town
marketplace it's called the poke please
and we're going to be sharing two family
recipes with you so the first dish is
going to be our take on a traditional
thai dish called
we used a pork shoshu made with pork
belly we
roll it up into this beautiful meat
parcel so you have like a slab pork you
just roll it up and then you take twine
and you tie off one end and then you
keep moving down tied up the pork belly
until you have it all the way through
you want to make sure that it's tight
otherwise it'll fall apart when it's
boiling so after the pork's all tied up
we just quickly sear it in the pot
so the broth has a bunch of different
components we start off with sake urine
soy sauce and then we add brown sugar
star anise coriander black pepper and
then after that we add crushed shallots
whole garlic and crushed ginger
and we steep it overnight but if it's in
it you're like you're out of time you
can do it like four to six hours once
it's nice and cool we take out the
fridge and we slice it and then we sear
it so you can either use a really hot
pan or a torch if you have one we prefer
using the torch just because it gives it
a nice beautiful char right on the
outside yeah when it's popping it's mean
it's it's it's fried right yeah it's
done yeah it's good next we're going to
teach you how to make the sauce so we
start off with hiki no or bird's eye
chilies we put in an even amount of
garlic fish sauce sugar
and lime juice so you can do this like
in a food processor or blender you're
just going to start off with a bed of
rice you're going to put cork toshu
right on top and then right on top of
the pork you're going to put the
thai
chili lime sauce
and you can top it off with sesame seeds
or green onions or really anything you
want after that you're gonna add your
soft boiled egg and that's how you make
our version of a cow cow
our next dish is a thai lab we have
adapted it and made it so that it tastes
really good with raw fish or sashimi
first off we start off with toasting all
the dry ingredients in a pan the spices
we start off with are
dried thai chilies we also use shallots
lemongrass coriander and garlic once
you've toasted all those ingredients
you're going to want to put them into a
food processor and blend them until
they're smooth you're going to set them
on the side for a little bit take a pan
and you're going to cook thai shrimp
paste you're going to add some oil and
throw in all that stuff that you got
from the blender or the food processor
by the final stage it should be like
almost like a paste today we're going to
be using salmon i personally love salmon
you want to make sure that it's this
nice deep color you don't ever want to
buy fish if you're gonna eat it raw if
it smells fishy so we're cutting it
lengthwise so you're gonna be cutting it
against the grain after that you're
gonna cut into cubes i personally like
kind of big cubes but you can cut them
as small or as big as you want put in a
few spoonfuls of that lab sauce you're
going to mix it in and then you're going
to throw in cilantro mint and we also
put in something called hot pound it's
like a
bamboo leaf but it's smaller it's softer
you are just going to put it over a bed
of rice i personally like topping it off
with fried garlic red onions and then
some more green onions on top and then
we garnish it with some thinly sliced
radishes and that's how you make our lab
pokey
so good super good
[Music]
you